[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of Harry Potter theory in
today's video we're going to be
discussing Dumbledore Voldemort and the
Elder one more specifically we're going
to be discussing a popular fan Theory
which suggests that Dumbledore was never
the true owner of the Elder Wand the
Elder Wand was the first hallow created
made by death himself and it was said to
be the most powerful wand that ever
existed the Elder Wand is made of Elder
wood and its core is the tail hair of
Athol it's 15 in long and has carvings
down its length that resemble clusters
of elderberries with the Elder Wand
witches and wizards have historically
been able to produce intensely powerful
magic that others could only dream of
some magic is actually altogether
impossible without the Elder Wand
including things like mending are the
one ons we see this powerful artifact
pass hands on numerous occasions
throughout the Harry Potter story and
its ownership is of utmost important to
the plot after all it's the ownership of
the Elder W that eventually allows Harry
to defeat Voldemort firing his own
killing curse right back at him but
before Harry became its owner in his
final showdown with Voldemort the end of
the Deathly Hallows who were the true
owners conventionally It is believed
that Dumbledore was the owner followed
by Draco who decied arm Med Dumbledore
followed by Harry who disarmed Draco but
one popular fan Theory suggests that
Dumbledore was never the true owner at
all so where does that leave us the main
driver behind the theory is how the one
actually changes ownership
conventionally It is believed that a
witch or wizard can only become the true
Master of the wand if they best the
previous owner but what is best mean
while it was originally suggested that
besting a wizard meant defeating them
the Harry Potter story seemed to suggest
later on that besting can include an act
as simple as disarming I.E Draco with
Dumbledore but is that true the theory
in question suggests that disarming is
definitely not a valid way of obtaining
ownership and that in order to become
the true owner of such a powerful object
you need to take it forcefully
commanding the one's respect if we Trace
back the W's history we can see that
Dumbledore took the W from grindlewald
and if we look at how Wald obtain the
wand we can see that he did so in a
cowardly manner stealing it from mq
gregorovich in the night gregorovich
burst into the room at the end of the
passage and his Lantern illuminated what
looked like a workshop wood shavings in
gold gleamed in The Swinging pool of
light and there on the window ledge sat
perched like a giant bird a young man
with golden hair in the split second
that the Lantern's light illuminated him
Harry saw the Delight upon his handsome
face then the Intruder shot a stunning
spell from his wand and jumped neatly
backward out of the window with a crow
of laughter the theory is this because
grinder Wald stole the wand in a
cowardly fashion he was never its true
owner and because dumore took the one
from grindlewald who was not its true
owner he himself could not have become
the true owner this means that for years
and years even though it was not in his
possession Miku gorovich was the true
owner of the Elder one but if all of
this is true how did Harry end up
becoming the one's true owner
did he well it starts with Voldemort
becoming the owner Voldemort who wanted
to escape the unique circumstances
regarding his and Harry's ones ended up
tracking down olivander after finding
him Voldemort tortured and interrogated
him for information pertaining to the
Elder Wand to this olander reveals that
he had heard a rumor that Miku
gregorovic still had it in his
possession the prospect of obtaining a
the most powerful wand in the world and
B an instrument that could defeat Harry
was extremely intriguing to Voldemort
and so he vowed to track down
gregorovich for months Voldemort tracked
gregorovich down even murdering a family
that lived in his former residence along
the way eventually however Voldemort
does find gregorovich and it's at this
point that gregorovich reveals that the
one was stolen from him years ago
Voldemort who did not believe him ended
up using legilimency to infiltrate his
mind and it was at this point that
volore saw the truth a vision of the
wand being stolen from him years ago to
this Voldemort then demands to know who
the thief was something which
gregorovich reveals he never found out
at this point gregorovich who pleaded
with Voldemort for Mercy was no longer
of any use to him and is killed by
Voldemort's killing curse at this point
the theory suggests that Voldemort
without even knowing it had become the
Elder one's true owner this means that
grindlewald was never the true owner
after stealing it from gorovich and it
also means that Dumbledore wasn't the
true owner after defeating Grindelwald
though Voldemort became the true owner
by killing gregorovic the one still
wasn't in his possession he would need
to track it down eventually however he
does finally wield the wand the only
issue is that this fabled powerful wand
is just not living up to his
expectations he tests it out time and
time again and believes that there is no
difference between his ordinary wand and
this powerful magical artifact he
eventually comes to the conclusion that
it's not a problem with the wand but a
problem with him yes he now held the
Elder Wand in his possession but from
his perspective because Snape had killed
Dumbledore Snape was the true owner not
him this meant that the W would never
work to its full capabilities it's not
until Voldemort finally kills Snape that
he becomes completely satisfied what the
theory suggests here is that though he
was the rightful owner at this stage the
reason he lacked power was for reasons
unrelated to the wand or the W's
ownership Voldemort didn't lack power
because he wasn't the true owner he
lacked power because pieces of his soul
were being destroyed he was the owner of
the Elder one now sure but many pieces
of his soul had been destroyed without
him even realizing it making him weaker
and weaker when Harry scores a victory
of Voldemort later in the story
destroying him it's only at that point
that Harry becomes the true owner this
theory is only reinforced by Rolling who
seems to suggest that it takes a great
deal for the wand to properly change
allegiance The Elder Wand is simply the
most ruthless of Wands in that it will
only take into consideration strength
one would expect a certain amount of
loyalty from Once wand so even if you
were disarmed while carrying it even if
you lost a fight while carrying it it
has developed an affinity with you that
it won't give up easily if however a
wand is won properly won in an adult
Jewel then a wand may switch Allegiance
however the Elder Wand knows no loyalty
except to strength it's completely
unsentimental it will only go where the
power is so if you win then you've won
the wand you don't need to kill with it
but almost inevitably it attracts
Wizards who are prepared to kill and who
will kill and also it attracts Wizards
like Voldemort who confuse being
prepared to murder with strength in
essence this Theory closes the plot hole
that simply disarming your opponent
counts as besting them what do you guys
think of this Theory had you heard of it
before let me know in the comment
section below if you enjoyed the content
please like the video and subscribe to
the channel until next time it does not
do to dwell on dreams and forget to
live